that's the charismatic CEO of we work at
immunity to doing something that says
intention or meaning in it you cannot
feel the feeling that you have right now
of being together this feeling of being
happy that's what we work is it is an
idea that's shared by a lot of startups
that your work should be more than just
something that you do 9:00 to 5:00
Monday through Friday but really a
calling or a mission or something that
you feel truly compelled to do we work
believes that they're not just selling a
workplace but a community they really
think this idea of the community as some
things not measurable that very
effective in getting the workplace that
sort of spark of energy and human has a
term for this intangible energy I'm
pretty sure he would call it the power
of greed this is the story of how we
work turned work into a lifestyle and
wants to change the world
next the co-working giant we work is
amongst the most valuable startups in
the world but 2019 hasn't started as the
company may have been hoping now we work
is not working for software so Japanese
conglomerate announced Monday it's
investing in additional two billion
dollars in the co-working startup to
step back from the sixteen billion
dollar investment that would have given
Softbank a controlling stake in we work
the significantly smaller investment
from Japan's Softbank leaves we work
more vulnerable to a potential economic
downturn or slump in lease prices still
we work is plowing ahead and announced
in January its rebranding itself as the
week company with the ambitious mission
to elevate the world's consciousness
and it kind of sounds like a self-help
cult now so what does the week company
do the week company will consist of
three main verticals we work we live
which for now is just two buildings for
communal living and we grow which is a
$42,000 a year Elementary School in New
York when Miguel and I started this
company it the intention was can we
change the world
the idea for we work emerged from the
upbringing zuv Newman and his co-founder
Miguel McKelvey they both spent part of
their childhoods in communal living it
was really community and bringing people
together that we were both attracted to
the doors to the first we work location
opened in 2010 they started by renting
out desks and famously small fish tank
officers to freelancers and
entrepreneurs on a monthly basis
but the we work model has always been
about lively communal spaces most
weworks will have staff called titles
like community manager and they have a
pretty big say in the culture of a place
they may be organized happy hours or
speaking event or lunchtime meetings
that people can come to and sort of
network with each other we work wants
people to interact and to achieve this
they monitor help people use their
spaces we keep tremendous amount of data
things that people usually don't talk
about like where they get up and how
often do they go to the coffee or
actually literally a connect with other
people we work as an in-house social
media app used to book rooms and rate
working spaces like you would an uber
driver this app paired with data
harvesting sensors which has spread
around selected offices allows we work
to observe behavior based on that they
can make design tweaks and roll them out
in the next building and they have a
steady stream of buildings in
development to test those ideas on
they've put a lot of energy into growing
super super fast
in 2014 we work opened its first
international location in London fast
forward five years and they have 400
locations in 26 countries they're now
the largest private tenant in central
London Manhattan and Washington DC and
while it continues to expand at
breakneck speed we work has also shifted
its focus to much larger enterprise
customers the largest companies in the
world have been approaching us in saying
hey can you bring this community into
our company more than 30% of weworks
members now work at companies with 1,000
or more employees and I think this is
going to be a tricky thing for we we're
trying to balance the entrepreneurial
energy that's a big part of their brand
would be stability and revenue that
comes from these fortune 500 and large
companies
but despite all the changes the company
still markets itself as a community of
creators you're a creator and yura
creator and mobile creators we work
couldn't be happier than to give you the
$50,000 it's yours
that's Newman at one of we works creator
Awards events the company launched the
elevator pitch competition in 2017 and
opened it up to people outside of we
works network they distribute twenty
million dollars annually in prize money
to anyone with an idea and a plan it's
just another way that we work is trying
to build its brand like they really see
this
I'm sure the as a marketing expense and
that brand recognition is important as
the newly renamed week company branches
outside of office spaces success I'm not
convinced yet that they're gonna have
that sort of effect on the way we live
but yeah in terms of the way that they
affect our expectations about our
workplace I do think that they've
already probably made some big changes
in in what companies expect on what
employees expect the core of the week
company business is still about adding
value to the real estate they're leasing
if that's enough to weather an economic
slowdown remains to be seen
[Music]
you